possible that women want to be victims
so bad that they sometimes don't think
about it when they put themselves in bad
situations so for instance a girl that
will go out dress half naked and end up
walking home on her own like these are
things that you could actually plan
ahead for yeah so it's not like I mean I
get sometimes plans go to but we see it
way too often where girls are just half
naked walking the street at 2 am in the
morning that is a dangerous situation
yeah and when you point that out they'll
say that you're a misogynist and sexist
when you're like you know if you don't
want anything to happen maybe don't be
half naked don't walk at 2am